House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi says
it is good to have tension in the
Democratic Party and in that case things
are really great for Democrats entering
the midterm election season
correspondent Peter Doocy looks at the
wide divisions among Democrats which not
everyone in the party sees as a good
thing is being a moderate Democrat in
these midterms a liability New York
Mayor Bill DeBlasio just called his
Governor Andrew Cuomo a moderate as an
insult
California's Democratic Party is
declining to endorse its longtime
Senator Dianne Feinstein paving the way
for a more liberal challenger and in an
Illinois race senator Bernie Sanders
just endorsed a progressive primary
challenger two Democratic congressman
dan Lipinski that was more moderate
there are those who want to have a tea
party of the left in the Democratic
Party to match some portion what happens
to the Republicans but we need to have a
big party but strategists aren't so sure
the middle of the road leads back to a
house Majority the great thing about the
enthusiasm that the Democratic Party is
seen from folks who are further to the
left and more progressive than the
moderates is that it is bringing more
people into the party it is increasing
the enthusiasm now some Democrats are
warning against extremes we need
pro-life democrats democrats control DNC
chair Tom Perez who recently knocked the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee for putting out opposition
research on one Democratic primary
candidate tells Fox the infighting is
okay do we have spirited primaries sure
we do but we had spirited primaries in
Virginia last year and people came
around no concerns from the top Democrat
in the house either it is the most
exhilarating thrill to lead to be a
leader in a party that has that kind of
diversity of opinion creative tension
Jerry Brown once called it that's a
mantra embraced by the Senate Democrat
he just served on a national ticket that
lost we are a party that has tolerated
some pretty
diversity of opinions for a long time
and there are limits to the Democratic
Party's potential progressive turn is
there a danger in the party going too
far to the left do you think well that
won't happen in West Virginia but just
about everywhere else so far this cycle
it seems that the one lawmaker whose
endorsement gets the Democratic base the
most fired up is Bernie Sanders what is
not clear yet is whether or not
independence or undecideds are ready to
follow the lead of a Democratic
Socialist
Brett petty juicy on Capitol Hill Peter
thank you